What happens when 800 of the world’s most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Real
This is
The Champions
Football is in my veins
Also growth hormones
Forget John Terry
I’m the real “Mr. Steal Your Girl”
[unintelligible]
Could we do that one more time, Harry?
I didn’t quite catch that
[unintelligible]
Alright, can we just get an actor in here?
Board up your windows
it’s Harry Kane season
Ok, just one more time
Kevin, when Vincent goes here, you go here
David, you press high here
when Otamendi goes to space here
Remember, we have six seconds to win back the zone
SIX SECONDS
Got it?
No
You speak too fast
Can we just shoot some paintballs already?
Last year the guys went paintballing
after our loss in the FA Cup
Afterwards we won the Premier League
So, I think, why not we do it again this year?
It’s fun, yeah
I like to get into it
and like pretend I’m all American
whenever I’m doing gun things
Kyle Walker
Texas Ranger
It’s not bad, right?
Pretty good
Alpha Company spotted at 11 o’clock
Bravo Kompany, you ready?
I...I can’t do it
Oh come on it’s all in fun
No...I mean...
I just pulled my calf
Ow
It hurts
It’s just paint, Vincent
No, I pulled my other calf
Guys. They’re here!
Quickly! Counter! Counter!
Hmmm
Wait, we are not using this red paint
Scouse
Liverpool?
KLOPP!!
Ow
I actually got Paintball Shot of the Year for that
Yes. Got you.
OK, guys, be careful
Where there is one Red
there’s always another nearby
These bastards never walk alone
Kevin
De Groin-ah!
Haha! Let’s go, mates!
Take this, Liverpooool!
What are they doing?
They seem to be playing a game
but they have these upside-down frowns
and are making these sounds like “ha ha ha”
It’s called smiling and having fun
It’s overrated
Don’t get any ideas
Oh
now Pep appears to be yelling at someone
It’s Jurgen Klopp!
What!?
Ugh
They are not real rivals
I am Pep’s only true competition
He and dis German hack had fling in Bundesliga
and now everyone wants to act like
they are great adversaries
It is a disrespect to all of Manchester
and the history of the Derby
But even more important than that
it is disrespect to me
Klopp
Why do you have to ruin everything?
Our unbeaten season
our Champions League hopes
and now this!
We are just having a little fun
No
We are the fun team
Clearly, you have not seen “All or Nothing”
And clearly you haven’t seen James Milner’s Twitter
Ah yes
but everybody knows I’m the most quirky
likable manager in football
Probably
I’m just a normal guy
Exactly!
Wait
that was very likable
Damnit!
Well nobody is more likable than David Silva!
Except for Mo Salah
Gah! You truly are my greatest rival,
you clever Kloppo!
And you are mine
you brilliant bald Barcelonian!
Oh my God. Get a room, you two!
You’re not rivals
I’m your rival
I’m everyone’s rival
I’m the most decorated
I’ll be your rival, Jose
Not you